We got a need from TrueRife today. That said, we need to do an update. So, to
write if you're belonged to their email list, they sent out an email saying to
update to the new 6.2 program. I know we talked about this in the last week's
call. You said not to do it, but is this something that new that needs to be done?
Well, right now, no, you do not need to update to the 0.2. There's pros and cons to
it. You asked me last week, I'd say do not update to the 6.2. Now, you know, they've
fixed a lot of things. So, as I told you last week's Zoom call, the week before, was
kind of a nightmare week for us because nothing was working on the 6.2 program
for us. And I was on the phone with Jake, a good part of the week trying to get
things fixed. Well, hats off to them because they did some
dandy things to get things fixed. So, our programs would still, we would start
working again. So, that is good. So, currently, I'm very happy with the 6.2
program. Although, I did adopt grade 9. By right, at home, I've not upgraded it. I
think they still got bugs to work out. Currently, with the 6.2, you can't put it
on anything on auto runs. So, that's still an issue that they're still trying to
work out. So, the new 6.2 program is what we're talking about. So, currently,
everybody that's on this call is running the 6.0 program. I'm looking at anybody
on this call. And I've already upgraded to 6.2 and no, I don't believe so. If you
want to upgrade to version 6.2, you would be better offsetting your computer and
your right machine back to me and have me do it for you at this point in time. If
you have not upgraded to 6.2, I'd suggest you just wait a little until they get
more of the bugs worked out because there are still some bugs in the program. I
do think it's going to be an overall ultimately. And there may be a time that I
get to upgrade to 6.2, but by that time, they'll probably be on 6.3 or 6.4. Might be
a couple of months. Jake said they're working on 6.3 and 6.4, and that's going to be
even a better upgrade. I really like some of the things that he mentioned. We do have
some of our new patients that are on 6.2. Understand, getting to your program on
6.2 is a little different. So, I have this important claim, disclaimers, I
was a disclaimer, but information on the member site. So you can look at it. Also,
I created a video for 6.2 users to get to their, what I call their master program,
which is their personal program. It's just a little bit different. You have to go
to the, when you open up the true right program and you go to the screen or the
open program screen, which is really their home screen. You won't see your
program in it. You have to go to the left hand side and click on the documents folder.
And in the documents folder, you'll see a true right frequency file. You have to
click on that and you'll get to the program that I created for you. So it's it's an
extra couple steps, which for if you're used to running 6.0, you're like, oh,
we're not there. Two more steps. You're not used to that. This is all
brand new. It's no big deal. Now, with these people, I've also created a shortcut on
their desktop for the easiest access. So if you do decide to upgrade or something
happens to your computer, if your computer goes complete, you can't even get
6.0 anymore. So we have to upgrade you to 6.2, which is fine. But then I will do
that for you. And I will create a shortcut on your desktop for you to just click on
and it'll open up your program. So it'll save you, you know, from these other
two steps that you would have to do in the 6.2 program. And that could all be
changed again in the 6.4, 6.3. So just personally, I would not upgrade to 6.2,
yet unless your computer goes completely, if your computer goes completely,
then we don't have a choice. And I would wait till they get some of the bugs worked out.